scientists across the world are racing
to develop a corona virus vaccine but
once a vaccine is developed and approved
who gets it could be highly dependent on
the 2020 census which is already
underway if in a year or two years from
now we finally have vaccines the the
first thing that public health folks are
going to do is they're going to look at
the census counts by neighborhood and
say where do we push out vaccines this
year getting an accurate count of the US
population by the December 31st deadline
might be much harder because of the
corona virus if people don't participate
then there are great risk of getting
less vaccine than they should have
gotten it's it has real real
implications the census results also
determine where federal funding goes
some have actually said that it's
trillions of dollars billions and
billions of dollars every year flow down
to the local level and are used by
decision makers to make informed
decisions about roads schools health
care whether it's funding for hospitals
Medicaid or children's health insurance
the US government looks at census data
to figure out how to allocate resources
during a health crisis like the corona
virus pandemic in accurate 2020 census
does bode well for times when emergency
preparedness or first responders need
that information
looking at the health industry and
everything that's happening with Kovan
19 the official statistics of the United
States definitely will be used and come
into play historically though minority
groups such as African Americans Latinos
people on tribal lands and other rural
populations have been the hardest to
count these are considered hard to count
communities for a couple of reasons one
little - very limited access to
information around the census and around
most civic engagement issues I think
another piece is there is a huge
distrust for government which is why the
census
sans field workers to knock on doors to
collect data they also reach out in
person to the homeless and those living
in transitory locations like campgrounds
RV parks and hotels but during the
pandemic collecting data in person poses
a huge health risk that's why all field
operations have been suspended until
after April 15th as the Census Bureau
tries to figure out how to protect the
army of doorknockers from covet 19
meanwhile the agency is urging folks to
fill out the form online or over the
phone however it puts the hard to count
populations in an even more difficult
situation because the people that have
historically been the hardest count are
the ones that require individuals to go
knocking on doors to secure their
participation advocates also worried
that the census is just not a priority
during the pandemic it is very hard to
any moment where we have a global
pandemic and where people are struggling
to figure out how they're gonna put food
on the table if they're losing their
jobs amidst all that to ask folks to
prioritize the census is a very
difficult thing despite the challenges
presented by the coronavirus census
officials say there's not much
flexibility to extend the deadline since
the US Constitution mandates a census
every 10 years but when and where
possible we're making adaptations and
modifications to all of our operations
to ensure the safety of the public
and our staff because we just like
everyone else we're practicing social
distancing and we're ensuring that we
can lessen the spread of Kovan 19
you
[Music]